it's true what Larkin says about parents
they do mess you up they don't mean to
usually but they do
[Music]
by the time I'm 8
that's mania and anxiety are kicking in
and that mixed with a newfound fervor
for Christianity makes things lively by
age 11 bedtime stories are out and tales
of Hellfire are in according to dad me
and everyone I know are going to suffer
eternal agony unless we turn to Jesus oh
man I could save myself what about all
the people on TV all the players on
match of the day would have to wait in
the car park after games mr. Canton are
kicking people is a sin yes even if they
do support Crystal Palace by now dad is
relentless and the panic attacks are
regular running around the house
screaming delirious and things
deteriorate by 12 13 I'm crying
constantly struggling to get out of bed
and by 14 I'm starving myself at 15 I
have a year off school and be treated at
a psychiatric ward complex PTSD is a
variation on post-traumatic stress
disorder we associate that with people
affected by specific incidents in war or
after an assault or car crash the
complex variety refers to those who
endured repeat abuse usually at the
hands of caregivers it may have been a
religious parent a violent parent one
that drank sexually abused you
scapegoat it shamed or just ignored you
one common sign of complex PTSD is an
intensely critical inner voice that just
won't get off your back you know the one
that says things like you're useless
you've achieved nothing one negative
thought will kick in and then it all
come out to play oh and you look rubbish
naked oh by the way everybody hates you
I can't believe you just stood on that
snail and you like snails another sign
is flashbacks and these are often more
subtle than specific memories a
situation you're in now will remind you
even subconsciously of a time that you
felt overwhelmed for me it's social
gatherings
when I walk into a room I often feel
like I'm about to be humiliating
so my fight/flight instinct kicks in
hard at parties I'll often go to the
bathroom several times just to feel calm
I love bathrooms sitting on the bar
listening to the party downstairs a
practice bathroom sound effects too but
a sound the toilet roll makes when you
pull off the last sheet after that I'm
okay for a bit but then someone new will
come up and say hello
I'm Ted I'll get all adrenaline and just
leave there is no danger but the psyche
doesn't know the difference that's
complex PTSD in a nutshell sorry Ted
other signs a depression substance abuse
isolating yourself and avoiding
relationships you may have no clue why
you feel any of this but there is help
self-help books are a great place to
start especially if you're nervous about
therapy or talking to a friend therapy's
been great to someone to talk to help
join the docs give names to things I
also try to stay healthy and
clear-headed vegan diet exercise and
meditation and of course stand-up talk
about facing your fear of humiliation I
did get to make some peace with my dad
before he died a few years ago a tumor
on the brain felt strangely right for a
man so lost in his own mental chaos I
did love him he meant well he was just
negligent and confused and it caused
damage it's important to know where the
blame lies these feelings aren't your
fault and it can be helped so see it
like you see any injury listen to it
give it what it needs and remember it's
okay to feel bad but fear anxiety anger
depression ruin all of the good stuff
all of the fun and this is supposed to
be fun
you